And today in this
presentation, I
would like to share
with you how to scale
Shiny to thousands
of users. My name
is Damian Rodziewicz.
I am one of the founders
of Appsilon and I'm also
a technical person.
So I work hands-on on a lot
of projects that we have.
That's why I have a first hand
experience in scaling Shiny
applications.
Be sure to leave your questions.
I'd be happy to discuss them.
And you can contact me later.
If you have any further
questions to discuss.
So let me start with a
very simple success story
that I keep seeing
over and over again.
And I'm really
excited about this.
Thanks to Shiny, you and your
team are able to build
a successful app very quickly.
Sometimes it is just
a matter of days.
And you start having your first
clients, customers, users.
Very often these are internal
users in your own company.
You are helping them understand
to better their process
and go through the
process much faster.
And suddenly you
have more users that
are using your application.
Very often we see
that people who
start using your application
love it from the first day,
because the fact is that
thanks to Shiny, you are able
to implement new features very
fast, and Shiny is super flexible.
You just make the
changes on the go.
Everyone loves the application.
And that's exactly what
the people want to do,
because this is a
dedicated software that you
built for them.
Suddenly you realize
that you have
a huge amount of users that
are using your application.
And it starts
to become a problem because some
the reports show you that your
application is actually slow
or some will tell you that they
are blocked and they cannot
click around your application.
And this is usually
when you decide
to seek for the solution.
And these are
usually the questions
that we are asked: how
to make my app faster?
How to scale my
Shiny application?
How to build a scalable,
Shiny enterprise application?
And the one thing that I would
like you to first think about
is the fact that most
of those questions
usually start with
a question, "How?"
We are very used to trying
to find the solution as
fast as possible.
We want to find good
tips and tricks.
We want to understand
what's going on
and just apply new techniques.
But there are two
other questions
that are even more important
that you should be asking.
The first one is why?
And the second one is what?
Let me share with
you a quick story.
There was a client that
had their car broken down
and they went to the mechanic. The
mechanic looked at the car.
They realized that
the engine is broken.
They took the hammer and
just smashed the engine.
Then suddenly the engine
started working again.
And the client asked,
OK, that's awesome.
How much do I pay for
this simple service?
And the mechanic
says, you are going
to pay hundreds of dollars.
And the client wasn't
happy about it.
And they asked for the
invoice to see why exactly.
Hitting an engine with a
hammer actually costs $100.
And this is the contents.
These are the contents
of the invoice.
$1 for just hitting an
engine with the hammer.
But the $99 is because
the mechanic understands
why the engine is broken,
understands what the root cause
is, and then knows what
exactly to do to get rid
of this root cause.
And now before I jump
into why which I think
is the most fundamental question
that you should be asking,
let's talk about what.
So that you have
the whole context
of what we usually
do when we want
to scale the Shiny application.
So when you think
about scaling Shiny,
there are two groups of
actions that you can make.
The first one is called
vertical scaling,
and this is
increasing the amount
of users for one machine.
And you can do it in two ways.
The first one is just adding
more resources to your machine.
So add more CPU,
add more memory.
The second way
of vertical scaling
is making your Shiny
application leaner,
so allowing more
users to use it.
And the second group is the
horizontal scaling, which
is just adding more machines.
To put it in this
context, the first two
are actually fairly simple.
I know I am a very
often asked about how
to scale Shiny horizontally, how
to have multiple servers with
Connect.
Let me tell you this.
This is actually
very, very simple.
I'm going to share
with you resources
at the end of this presentation.
So that you can take a look
yourself on the contents.
But basically, the first simple
step that some people usually
do is just ask the DevOps/IT
if they can increase
the size of the server.
They add memory, they add CPU.
And this right away
gives you more users
that can use their application.
Of course, you have
to pay for that.
And very often it is difficult
to find additional budget
for increasing the machine,
especially if suddenly you
need.
So you have 10
times as much users.
And you need to really,
really big machine.
Then the second step that you
can do is talk to DevOps/IT
and ask for them
to add more servers.
This is as simple
as just spinning up
additional virtual machines.
If you are using Cloud or
a little bit more complex,
if you have like
physical machines
that you have to turn
on and configure.
But the good news
is that RStudio Connect
is super easy to configure.
There are just simple steps
that you need to go through
and suddenly all
of your machines
are going to run on Connect.
All of them are going
to run your application.
And the only thing it
costs you is actually
real money for the machines.
Now, the third thing
that you can do
is the most difficult one.
And the one that requires
you to understand why
the application may be slow.
And this is for
you as an R engineer
to find the bottlenecks.
And so to understand what
slows the application down
and to make the
application leaner.
There are three main
things that you can do.
Of course, there is much more
techniques that you can apply,
but the key parts
are first to leverage
the front end, to use JavaScript.
As you saw from the
previous presentations,
it's not that complex
and sometimes you
don't even need to
understand the JavaScript.
You use the server
to generate HTML and send
it back to you when you make changes.
It already saves you
very valuable time
of your processor. The second
one is to extract computations,
and this also decreases the
CPU usage of your application.
If your application is
doing something heavily,
think about a way to extract
those computations somewhere
else, to leverage the ability
to use external services
and not put all of the pressure
on your Shiny application
server.
And the third one, which is I
think the most commonly used,
is to just use a database.
I have heard a huge
amount of success stories
when someone just
decided to move
all of his data or her
data into the database
and suddenly the application
was easily scalable, up
to hundreds or
thousands of users.
This gives you two advantages,
which is less memory
usage and less CPU usage.
So this is more or less
what you need to do
to scale your Shiny application.
Now, I would like you to fully
understand why we actually
have to do this, because
when you think about it,
RStudio Connect is a great
product that allows you
to scale Shiny applications up
to tens of thousands of users,
you might have
seen Sean Lopp's video where
he shows how this is possible.
And also Shiny is very
fast on your local machine
when you just run it.
Why should it be
slower for others
when there is just
more people using it?
So let me tell you a story based
on a very simple application.
If you take a look at the code.
And this is like a most
simple one that you can write,
there is a slider and there
is a text output. The server,
the only thing that
the server does
here is the server
gets the input
slider value whenever
it changes and sends
the value back as output text.
Now, what happens
behind the scenes
when you send such
application to the server?
The first thing when the user
connects to the server
is the browser is going to
download HTML that is generated
by your UI function,
CSS, Javascript, all
the static files like images.
And at the same
time, server is going
to create a separate process
for you so that you can start
your Shiny session there.
And you can execute the R code.
Now the thing about processes
is that R is single threaded.
And you can specify
how many users you
want to have for one process.
But you need to realize that if
there are two users that have
the same process assigned
and since R is single threaded,
when one process does something,
then the other user cannot
actually do anything.
I will show you
this in a moment.
But what you should
understand here
is that the server
creates a process
or adds the user to a
already existing process
to handle all of the operations
on your reactive graph.
Now, the second
thing that happens
is the browser creates
a connection through web
websockets and through
websockets,
there are going to be
data and information being
sent back and forth.
Websockets are slightly different
than the typical REST API
that you know, because
they allow you to have
a bidirectional communication.
And that's why the
server can actually
push the messages to the
browser, which is not
that possible with a single
typical applications that
have a REST API.
So this is the second step
is the browser actually binds
the Shiny inputs and outputs.
And it starts the websocket
connection with the server.
Now, let's say that you
are moving the slider
and you set the slider to five.
The browser is going to send
this value to the server.
The server is going
to check this value,
trigger the reactive computation
and return the resulting value.
So in our example,
this is just going
to respond to the browser.
The text is 5.
Now, coming back to the
Pedros presentation,
if instead of just
returning a simple value
we return an updated
widget, then you
would actually have to
send the whole HTML.
If you don't use
the update function
that Pedro was talking about,
if you used update function,
then the browser is smart.
The browser receives only
the data that has changed.
And in java, on
the JavaScript part
is going to update the HTML.
So this is a huge value already
by using the update functions.
Now, when it comes to the
browser and the server,
after all of the
computations are done,
the browser is just
waiting for another signal,
either from the user
or from the server.
Now, this is a very
simple example.
Now let's take a look what
happens when you actually
start doing some
difficult computations.
So instead of just
returning the value
I'm going to perform a long,
complex CPU operation based
on the input slider value.
And now at the same
thing that happens,
you send the value through
the websocket to the server
and within that process
that is started for you,
the process is just calculating
the long running computation
that you're required it to do.
And the problem
is that your users
are no longer is able
to make any actions
within the application.
Everything is gray.
It is waiting for the output.
And at the same time, new users
or old users that have
already been using this process,
also cannot interact with
the server and have to wait
for this computation to finish.
And this is one
of the main issues
that we see in
applications when there
is plenty of complex
computations happening for one
users, the other
users are blocked
or the CPU usage is so
high that the other users
are seeing that things
are going slower for them.
So in order to get
rid of this problem,
you can use multiple solutions.
First one, extract some
computations to the database.
I will show you
this in a moment.
Second one, you can use
shiny promises, which
is a great package by Joe Cheng
that allows you
to move those computations
to a completely new process
and to make the Shiny
free from any computation
you can use shiny
worker, which
is our package for
similar computations.
Or you can simply move
some of the computations
to the Javascript,
to the front end.
Now let's talk
about the database.
This is the second
biggest problem
that I see in applications.
You might create a successful
application that works locally.
Fine, but in fact, the
application in order to run
loads a lot of data into memory.
And we need to realize
that our computers
are similar to what
we have as servers,
they have their own ram,
they have their own CPU,
and RAM usually is around
sixteen, 32 gigabytes.
It's not a lot, if
in your application,
you read one gigabyte
of data and then you
filter this data to do some
actions in the application.
Let's see what happens
in the real life.
You can see a machine here.
You can see five users that
are connected to RStudio Connect.
And in this configuration,
we create one process
for every two users
that's accessed our application.
This is configurable.
This is easy to configure.
But for this
purpose, let's assume
that we have to use
our spare one process.
Right now, if you
have five users,
you already have three
gigabytes of data
being loaded because
every process is
like a separate box
that contains everything
that you need to
trigger all of the data
to compute everything.
And now when you have, for
example, 13 users, suddenly
you need to have seven
processes and seven gigabytes.
Let's see if you have 26 users.
It already uses up to
14 gigabytes of data.
And when you think about
it, 26 users is not a lot.
So you should be very
aware of the fact
that the usage of
your memory is going
to multiply by the
amount of users
that you have in
your application
and you should try
to avoid loading
too much data into memory.
What you can do instead is to
set up a separate database.
And it doesn't have to
be a separate SQL server.
It could be files on your
drive on the machines drive
that are accessed
in a different way
than just loading all
of that into memory.
You can check out to
search online for Christian
Egross' talk about different
possible ways of reading data.
And even having a
separate package that basically
reads a lot of
files that terabytes
of data that you can search.
This is just files.
But when you have an
external database,
that database contains
this one gigabyte
and you just execute a filter
query and you get the result.
And here you have two gains.
First one is, of
course, the fact
that you don't have to
load the data into memory.
But the second one
also is the fact
that sometimes such
filtering is even faster
because the database
is especially
indexed to allow you to
make the queries very fast.
So just to recap, when you have
a successful Shiny application, most
likely from the start,
because it is a prototype,
it is going to look like this.
There is a server, there's UI,
a lot of communication
through the web
sockets and the server
is doing a lot of
computations by themselves.
The first thing to do, try
to leverage Javascript,
try to move some
computations to the browser.
The second part, use
external server.
You can use R API to create
a separate server that is going
to do the computations for you.
And then just ping
the main server
when the computations are done.
You can use the database, which
is the simplest way of already
giving you a lot of
edge, and then you
can just scale
horizontally by adding
the servers with your IT team.
Now, the other way to
think about it is you
don't want your application
to be a slow chess player.
You want your application
to be the Forrest
Gump of table tennis.
You want it to
just take the ball
and give it back, right away.
When when the application,
when the front end
is asking for something, you
just respond very quickly.
Hey, yeah, OK, I'm
going to do this.
And the front end knows
that something is triggered.
Then you just delegate
your job somewhere else.
And once the job is
done at the front end,
know that something has changed.
This is similar to
the comparison that I have in
my head, is that you don't want,
for example, your mother to come
into your room and tell you,
hey, now you have
to do your homework
and I'm going to stand here
and wait until you are finished.
You want just to say,
hey, do the homework,
and I will be back or
when you're finished.
So this is the kind
of way you want
to structure your application.
Now, to sum it up, I would
like to tell you also
how to do this.
There is plenty of resources
that you can reach.
We will share the
slides with you.
So we can click
through those things
and to see different articles
under a separate section
for leveraging front end.
There is a very nice book
about JavaScript for R
and there is a section for
extracting computations.
The shiny worker package,
shiny promises package, plumber
API, great, great
resources that you can just
jump into and start working
with. For using a database
I recommend using the reading
the main article from RStudio
that actually goes
through every step
that you need to have the
database in your application
and to scale vertically
and horizontally.
There is a very nice
page about scaling
and performance tuning
for the dataset.
That gives you an overview
of all of the configuration
options, especially how many
users you use for the process.
And there is a separate doc
about high availability,
how to scale your
application horizontally,
how to add additional servers.
As I said, this is
like really simple.
Don't worry about
it, just try it.
You can even log into
AWS or Google cloud,
set up the virtual
machines, install RStudio
Connect and see how
easy it is to configure.
That is all from me.
Thank you very much.
Hope this is useful.
And I'm looking forward to the
next talk by Marek and Fillip.